this week conflict zone is in Geneva
home of the United Nations headquarters
in Europe my guest
is Martin Kobler head of the UN mission
in Libya thousands of refugees are
making the dangerous journey to Europe
does he believe the UN can bring hope to
Libya
[Music]
Martin Kobler welcome to conflict zone
it's a pleasure to be everything as you
enter the position as head of the United
Nations support mission in Libya you
said your goal is to prevent Libya from
becoming the next Syria have you managed
to achieve that well this is a very
ambitious goal but we managed so far to
achieve it it's ambitious you managed it
or you didn't yes and we did because you
do not read as much about Libya in the
media then you read about sir but that's
not the point to read or not to read
Libya is again a state of profound
crisis three different governments
competing for power and resources and
the majority of the country is still at
war what a failure well just let me
contradict your emmechelle I mean the
country is not at war it's not even a
civil war how many people there's
violence there is my aggressive ities
criminality her mentality
Edge's so this is more a civil war or
criminal war but there is a situation
that the population is endangered indeed
that's why we are working for making the
situation better for them but it is not
it is much better than it is in Syria
and it did not slide into total chaos
yes they are rival governments and yes
there is criminality and the country
does not have a central authority as in
other states also but it's it's
contained the conflict so far is
contained but I do not want to belittle
the problems that's why we are there and
we're just doing it because reports of
massive human rights violations the
collapse of justice and financial system
it doesn't sounds like there's much
between Syria and Libya with one
different there is not the active war
the rest is similar well we managed in
the last year to have a government of
national unity which is recognized by
the international community wait no it
has to firstly as I learned it has to be
recognized by the population it isn't
the oil production went up
there is money cultural gallery you said
that the black government is recognized
by the international community I ask you
again is it recognized by the population
it's not recognized by all the sellers
what is that where the authority there
is no state authority is it government
or is it a paper no it is a government
which is it with a limited authority
there are other rival government center
this is the situation as it is that the
other members have the authority legal
questions
policy whatever or is it only a little
bit showdown to have the opportunity to
say Libya is getting better we have a
government well during the last year
there was the fight for example to
answer your question against the Islamic
state when I came to the country huge
areas of the Gulf of Sidra dominated by
the Islamic state like a Caliphate the
government of national Accord
I mean steered the fight against ties
with American airstrikes support and
today - the business model model of - is
integrated with a so-called Islamic
state is still existing also existing in
Libya but let's be honest after our
criterias Libya is a failed state isn't
it no authority of government no
authority of that what we know is the
minimum of a state building you did it's
a failed state
I would not categorize it as a failed
state it is a state where we had a peace
accord which the Libyans signed way back
in December 2015 does this government
has any authority in his own country
this government has authority in his own
country as I tried to explain to you the
authority was to fight the Islamic state
and do not belittle the problem of
Islamic state it was a highly fart
torturing people which stretched over
240 kilometers in the Gulf of cert this
is an end now the force is
loyal to the president's accountant the
governor of national record Adama can
use those cases again you mix both cases
regardless of that what you just told us
my question is again we know that even a
dictatorship is something else than a
failed state because there is the
authority of the dictator here in Libya
would you say there is any authority in
the country no there are many
authorities and you have to Snoddy you
have to start one of the government many
you have to start in a fragmented state
which was suffering from 42 years of
Gadhafi dictatorship and by the way also
Gaddafi created the illusion of a state
yeah he was the strongmen that they were
never in Libya strong institutions and
it doesn't come overnight to build up
strong inside I want to quote you here
is what you said to the Security Council
just a few weeks ago we should be honest
enough to see that the optimism and
confidence of schilit that means the
peace agreement has faded instead I see
you are the one frustration
disappointment sometimes anger and often
it is justifies this is a declaration of
bankruptcy isn't it no not at all this
is a declaration of hope this is an
encouragement to go to a better world
and to go back a better Libya but the
state of today is instead I see
frustration disappointment and anger
this is the status of today right right
your mission headquarters are stationed
in Tunis is that so well we have our
main office in Tunis however we are
working from inside Libya why are you
not in Libya if things are going better
I just tell you we are moving to Libya
and our preparations have been made and
you will see in the next months that we
are moving with all our office into
Libya for security reasons
is not like Iraq or other countries
there is no unified security structure
it's worse the security situation is
worse the security situation is much
more fragmented I say so worse it's not
worse there are no bomb explosions like
in butter that you don't want to be
there it didn't be there nope we want to
be there the decision is made we would
end by the way we were there until 2014
we were evacuated and we are going back
preparations are made and watch TV you
will see in the next months that we are
going back we have to end by the way we
are working from inside Tripoli but not
in a public way yeah but it means there
was some let's speak about the
legitimacy of the government how much
the jessamy does the government of
national Accord the GNA which is backed
by your bosses at the UN half well they
lack legitimacy like the other
institutions also the Parliament likes
legitimacy there are only a few people
coming to the meetings the institutions
like legitimacy
this is affect and we are working to
make it better for the people who are
suffer from this situation but if a
government has a lack of legitimacy
isn't the problem by itself by
definition yes it is a problem members
of the GNA itself say it has failed in
January 1 of its deputy leaders resigned
saying I quote I don't think we are
unaware of what the citizens are
suffering but we are incapable and I
admit that we are failures because we
didn't solve the problems and the UN and
you are still backing this failed
government why lack of alternatives it
is the lack of alternatives if you want
to get out of a civil war and this we
did we negotiated peace agreement the so
called
Libyan Political Agreement having a
presidency Council a parliament and this
kind of second chamber so one has to
start with the first step and after 42
years after the
of Gaddafi dictatorship after the
revolution after the civil war you have
to start with the first letter
discussing over this argument lack of
alternatives I'm listening to this
argument since plenty of years and very
often because of this argument of
international community of America or
the Russians decided to support a person
or government and this was even worse
than that what happened before and here
it's better here it is better we have a
presidency Council which went into
Tripoli on the 1st of April last year
would you have thought that it would be
still in Tripoli in May 2016 more than
one year later with no army in place
with Salafist jihadist with other armed
groups mafia groups around in Tripoli
that a fledgling government is still in
Tripoli with ours in Tripoli very often
they have to meet at the military union
because their own security perspective
is a very very bad one I mean the
failure is not you to the political
constellation maybe maybe it is also
because the sides have lost confidence
in you personally yes true we have our
opinion polls and the confidence we
always check the trust factor in the
United Nations and of course in the
busts of the United Nations there is a
considerable portion of the stakeholders
who just want us out in order to do
their own business yes in particular the
human traffickers of course they say
they don't have conflicts elliptical I
can do they can do what they want they
can even do what they want till today
and even the UN is there it is always
difficult to prove negative facts what
if the trainings would take not take
place but there may be more refugees
coming but I agree that human
trafficking is one of the most serious
and appalling problems of the country
that's why state authorities to come
back to this country that's what we are
working not only the
criminals accusing you the Liberal Party
accuse you
this April few weeks ago for being
biased and working against Libyan
interest to it by attempting to settle
African migrants in Libya well this is
nonsense because I never requested this
you see Germany has free media where are
the free media in Libya every media
norske were are they in other countries
of the world I'm working in Libya not in
Moscow now in Libya we have a problem of
communication every warlord every party
is generous Rebecca is just Khalifa
Haftar a warlord general Khalifa Haftar
is the general command of the Libyan
National Army who is he a warlord or is
a commander of the Libyan National Army
or is the same no I said he is the
commander of the Libyan National Army
who does not recognize the presidency
Council the agreement forces very
clearly let me say this that the
presidency counts it's the supreme
commander of the Libyan army which is
not respected we're after
exactly which is not respected by after
that's why I was with after our last
time two weeks ago I met him and term I
just also here now in Geneva we have
there we are doing this interview having
meetings you see to bring about you but
you are not the only one after is
frequent visitor to Moscow his army
receives support and training Byram
Russia what do you think is Russia's
motivation in Libya the same one as in
Syria well you have more information
than myself about the support and the
terrain the man don't be naive you know
that the Russians are in Libya and they
have ended after is a part of it I tell
you that you have more information than
myself I know about many who are in
Libya but not the Russians yeah
however the haft are frequently visits
Moscow your right is receive a snake in
Holland he is doing holidays there no he
is he's going to Moscow in order to
really political support is in Conakry
aunt is in Cairo as well once every
month he is in Cairo
in order to gain political supporters
things because Russia is also very
influenced in Cairo is Russia in Russia
is a member of the Security Council of
the United Nations being very much bound
by the Security Council resolution
Russia is one of my bosses and they are
the ones supporters early in politics of
what does it mean Russia is one of your
bosses well that they support the Libyan
Political Agreement they gave us they
say they support like in Syria they
support constructively or it's a
destructive no it's a construct it is a
constructive cause again the Security
Council I see a constructive role of
Russia together with the other members
of the Security Council about Syrian
political agreement I'm responsible for
Libya not for Syria I see a constructive
role in the Security Council and I as
you quoted have to report to the
Security Council once every three months
I see a constructive role of Russia
there are other players who have roles I
mean other regional powers and I
encourage everybody to use their
respective relations to their
constituency in a constructive but let's
speak about this general huffed us el
and a they have been accused of the
killing of women and children illegal
detentions summary executions torture
after is a relic of the old regime do
you believe he can be a constructive
part of a peace settlement such a man I
mean these human rights violations I
take up regularly with the Libyan
National Army and also with General
after himself if you read even my public
statements I also in contact with the
International Criminal Court with the
general prosecutor fatou Bensouda yes I
what about him he's a criminal your
question your question was whether he
should have a role in the setup of the
army the answer is yes how do you feel I
mean listening to you how do you feel
when negotiating with alleged mass
murderers well the gay rights violations
have to addressed and I do it
doing publicly I do it discreetly we do
what we can how do you think I'm in
contact with the the International
Criminal Court that's that's how it is
we have to work with those forces who
are on the ground according to Human
Rights Watch Libya has now about half a
million internally displaced people much
of this happened under US supervision no
it's not it did not happen under our
supervision because we are the United
Nations with a separate mandate we do
not have an executive mandate in the
country I'm not Paul Bremer here
yeah Paul Bremer was different and you
judge yourself whether this works the
international community decided not to
have an executive mandate there was a
trust to ship of the UN after they after
the independence this is not the way we
go there is not a Paul Bremer there is
not as the UN is working in Kosovo where
there is an executive element it's not
like Bosnia Herzegovina no we try to
organize the process called the Libyan
quality are you successful are you
successful last year you said to the
Italian people a stand up vote it is
crucial to re-establish security in the
country to counter human trafficking and
that it is intertwined with terrorism
this is your mandate how successful are
you it's these are your words the
question is how successful are the
Libyans I think you did not really
understand the system what we are doing
it is up to the Libyans to organize
their state its Libyan ownership its the
Libyan sovereignty our role is to
organize the process to enable the
Libyans to establish their security
structure this is how the system work in
other countries it was decided
differently
so let's come back to the the refugees
hundreds of thousands of refugees from
Africa are passing through Libya every
year on their way to Europe in the
desperation they are being exploited
used even enslaved by Libyan militias
what are you and what have you done
until now to change this
tragic reality well this is really if
you if you ask how I feel here I feel
very frustrated now I go to these
migration camps once every few weeks and
I see these people suffering and they
tell me their stories how they lost
their families who were pushed out of
away from the tracks from Eritrea from
Somalia from other countries Nazaire now
what are we doing here
the there are several several things we
are doing first of all we are improving
the situation in the detention centers
these people are in the detention
centers of the Libyans we just make sure
that there is enough space to bring no
authority no police nobody is listening
to this government in Libya in the case
of the migrants let me prove you wrong
please and let me severely contradict
you there is a governmental anti
anti-immigration Authority which is
working they are working in 23 of the
camps we try to be with them in the
camps financing the camels and mr. let
me also mr. Coppola
you don't know clear clear
recommendations to the government yet
they are ticklish in order to our
recommendation bangla situation
realities libya is were 90 percent of
boats crossing the central Mediterranean
are lounged the G and a took a deal with
the Italian government to stop the ships
but the Parliament in Tobruk stuck it
down yes you're right this is not this
is a big human tragedy and the solution
is to work for the implementation of the
agreement and to have unified security
structures and the restitution of state
authority as we agree that there is no
state authority in the country neither
in the south not east and the west now
our plan together with the Libyans is to
implement these data Thorat again
general after our home you mentioned
plays a role other player the militias
have to disappear at the end of the day
this they have to be mobilized
I want to ask you something when is the
end
today I will not answer this question
when nobody can answer is not this year
not next year not in two years because
if it is two years you could answer to
this question it I do not answer the
question of timelines because this time
Lance cannot be answered but I know the
timelines of the past 42 years of
Qadhafi dictatorship who did not allow a
strong army who had the artillery in the
east and the ammunition of the artillery
in the West better like what was better
no strong institutions no strong state
institutions and it takes some time to
institute this agency charge a fee or
without Gaddafi in Libya
Gaddafi's system was overruled by the
revolution we have to deal with the
situation we have now Arabs revolution
the Revolution was done in and Gaddafi
was went every spring which was also it
was a situation where everybody was so
happy also the Western countries it was
a mistake or not it was an illusion or
not there wasn't one Syrian big militia
they were in the case in the case of
Libya it was a mistake that the country
was left alone after the Revolution yes
I mean one cannot say we intervene and
then you continue with your revolution
alone I mean the intervention of 2011 I
think we all agree in hindsight should
have there should have been a second
step namely a very strong involvement of
the international community in the build
up of the country and not to withdraw
and observe the situation that's a
remark which brings the next question
your mandate in Libya as in many places
before to help facilitate democratic
transition and to promote the rule of
law so many hopes so many deceptions
indeed I couldn't agree more I couldn't
agree more that during the revolution
levels there was hope and I also
acknowledge that
was the mistake of the international
community then to have withdrawn and to
have said you do your revolution alone
can you understand we have to live with
the situation and make the life manifest
and why only few still trust the UN yes
of course by the way the trust factor is
much higher in Libya than in any other
of the of the missions I was running so
far so the trust factor of the UN you
see every if you read this everybody
criticizes you and there is a scapegoat
factor for certain failures the Libyans
should do themselves I mean is it really
like that I mean don't you feel
sometimes that you are being used and
that the UN serves as an alibi for the
interest of Russia China America Saudi
Arabia Iran and a lot of other countries
for their own interest and then you are
stylish that the UN has no confidence
anymore no I'm not astonished at all
because I totally agree
the our work is typically that we have
to take care that we are not too overly
manipulated but not only by regional
powers but also by the Liberal Party
whom do you mail your bosses Russia
Russia is destroying a lot then in the
UN The Alibi is working and everything
is still not good am i the UN Charter
the political Bible for the protection
of human rights democracy freedom of
speech rule of law the broad majority is
stumping on these human rights in the UN
room full of hypocrites and double
standards well you see the good thing of
my job is that I can address these
questions of the values of the United
Nations very clearly we are impartial
but we are not neutral
I represent the values of the United
Nations and I speak up at each and every
occasion what about China Russia what
about North Korea mean where are you
starting and when are you ending this
list well it's very clear I'm starting
with Libya and I end with
because my mandate is Libya detention
centers the situation is untenable
it's cruel it contradicts every human
human kind of spirit it contradicts the
value system of the United Nations I'm
not tired to mention this be it the
fragile government be it general have
diabete
and you quote things out of my speech I
mean quote also the things where I
publicly in front of the Security
Council speak up for Human Rights Martin
Kobler thank you very much for being in
conflict so thank you very first girl
it's a pleasure thank you very much
[Music]
you
[Music]